all right the patriots trying to take
the edge off on their receiver room cam
newton answering questions about whether
and to what extent the patriots have
what they need or whether they need to
enhance their receiving core as they try
to build on a one-on-one start here is
cam newton from weei
on tuesday talking about whether or not
the answers to their problems at
receiver are already on the team
do you feel like you need
uh another receiver would you like to
see the patriots do something when it
comes to that position
man i'll say this
the answers are in that locker room
simply play
you know we got a little bud doughboy
highway 11
and you know my germs so we we good to
go and um so oh we have to let me never
rewind that we have damir bird
nikhil harry
dewey edelman
and jacoby meyer
so those are the guys and look edelman
and harry are getting it done damir bird
flashed in the game against the seahawks
jacoby myers hasn't done much he's got
one catch for seven yards is that enough
or do you think they need to enhance i
mean will this work in progress get
better or should they look for something
from the outside they did last year
giving up a second round pick from
muhammad sunu near the trade deadline i
think they're going to continue to
evaluate as they go i do think there
it's enough for right now but i mean but
but yeah we're still early where we are
and you could see there is potential
with the group i do think it's a group
that will continue to get better i mean
damir byrd is a guy that you know yeah
in arizona been around a little bit but
he's an experienced player and kill
harry you're seeing him just getting
used to the nfl you know but then i
think the big thing is we know they got
julian edelman and and you said it
jacoby myers who was more dependable
last year and in the flow and so he's
there as a backup but the other thing
you always take into account with them
too
is of course they're running backs and
like rex burkhead is a receiver running
back you know james white not having him
there last sunday night you know that
hurts them his ability to catch the ball
out of the backfield do those things so
they have enough to where in the new
england way they'll find other guys to
take up some of those roles that maybe a
receiver would do this but we'll get you
know our running back or we'll make the
receiver move to here in some creative
formation to get it done uh i do think
there's enough but i think like new
england always does they'll they'll be
evaluating and watching how this goes
through the next few weeks
yeah and look it's working that is right
the bottom line regardless of the names
involved when cam newton has the kind of
knight he had against the seahawks with
the significant uptick in passing
production it doesn't matter who the
guys are and the way it works is when
you have games like that the guys on the
team become stars they become the guys
that people know about they become the
guys whose jerseys are purchased who you
pick up on your fantasy team who you
can't wait to see what they do next and
you don't need to use draft capital for
next year to try to make the team better
this year so
i think but now now still odell beckham
jr would dramatically enhance that
offense if cleveland decides at some
point before the trade deadline to
dangle him and the patriots are
interested but they may be fine without
him they could be great with obj but it
looks like they're going to be just fine
with the guys they have assuming they
stay healthy yeah well i think the the
thing that you have to be worried about
is there's not a lot of wiggle room for
injury with the group because they're
not real on the roster they don't have a
ton of wide receivers there so one of
them goes down you're going to start to
go ooh all right now they're in a little
bit of a bind here and probably going to
have to you know sign somebody or
continue to look out on the street to
see if anybody's there but when you do
look at the receivers you know of course
we know julian edelman can do it all i
mean just amazing what we saw him do
last week it really was at that age
you'd be running down the field past
jamal adams and things like that so you
got him who can work the middle of the
field and do everything you got a demir
bird who's a little bit more of a speed
guy and can win on the outside he can
run go routes and comebacks and then you
gotta kill harry which is a guy that
like cam newton's been very used to in
his career right the devin functions uh
the the devon functions the uh kelvin
benjamin's those bigger type receivers
oh he's covered i'll just throw it up
back shoulder so they have a little bit
of everything in the receiving core i
guess is what i'm saying and the other
thing i found cool about that clip it
just tells you
i already where he's at you know as far
as cam newton i mean he's got a nickname
for all of them right i mean he's
calling them the nickname and then he
wants to make sure he gives them the
proper respect so he goes back and says
their names the right way uh i just
think that was an a cool little inkling
into the leadership of cam newton and
how he kind of interacts with the team
it was a great interview by cam newton
yesterday talked about how the contract
is the last thing on his mind getting an
extension getting a raise no he's
focused on football he is all in on the
patriot way and it's worked so far yeah
they could be slash maybe should be 2-0
but one-on-one's a great start when one
of those games was a trip across the
country that's right on a great seahawks
team they get a chance to get to two and
one this weekend against the raiders
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports